welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and now that the TVA has a hit on
Rona Ren slayer's location we are left
wondering where exactly she might be
Additionally the news that she's working
with Miss minutes raises the question
why what do these Kang number twos need
from each other what are they planning
to do that requires them to be hidden
for the rest of the TVA and what do
either of them know about rona's secret
history with he remains this is the
sneak peek where we take the temperature
of whatever we're watching ing while we
head into the next episode or look ahead
to the next week in nerdom joining me on
this episode formerly my Wookie freak
now turn Marvel geek Tomo o for those of
us that are fans of both both Ren Slayer
and Miss minutes we're about to be
eating good o ooh ooh ooh ooh ooh Eric
you know I've been a big supporter of
Miss minutes in her love affair with
cogsworth on the break room but it
sounds like Miss minutes it says a new
partner raona Ren Slayer
M isn't is that what I've been waiting
for my FanFiction come alive but why
what is Miss minut helping with exactly
why that's our new catch for this is
just asking why kind of in a Mis minute
voice why ah why why what is raona and
Miss M's plan you know it's I think
we're giving them a lot of credit by
saying they even have a plan I think
they both only have half of a Playbook
you know it's clear that this season of
Loki is mapping on City Slickers 2
the Quest for Curly's gold and that each
of these Partners have half of a map
half
half and then only by joining forces by
finding their mutual love for each other
will they be able to complete the map
and figure out where to go next yes um I
think uh look um I think they clearly
each had a relationship with uh with the
Kang variant he remains he remains is
dead now so we know based off a trailer
footage that we're going to see the the
office of he remains we're going to go
back there but it's like in the process
of crumbling based off of that one sh so
I think the person who may go back there
is one of these two characters seeing
what happened there uh and and like
figuring out what their relationship was
but like I think the the answers to this
question Tommy are all in that Citadel
that's why it's I think so important to
go back and watch season 1 episode 6
when we first visited the Citadel uh you
know there's a fourth broken timekeeper
statue there's a whole barricaded region
of the Citadel that like no one can
access that might have been like you
know the the place that the love nest of
he remains and of U Ren Slayer I mean
maybe that was like a nursery they were
building oh God was Miss minutes their
baby no that'd be crazy baby
minut baby I might have destroyed that
statue yeah they'll make your nightmares
come true hey y
hey
why why uh if you look closely at Miss
minut stockings they're green and white
strip she's Nanny oh my God you're right
she was their Nanny oh my God she was
The Hand That Rocks the Cradle Tomy oh
The Hand That Rocks the Cradle is the
fist that rules the world don't forget
that yeah yeah yeah no I I think like uh
there was clearly like a love triangle
going on here um and I think Ren Slayer
might have been the fourth statue I
think Miss minut might have smashed it
oh oh uh and then I think that now she's
like now she's feel spurned by he
remains and I think the two of them are
kind of like the ghost of girlfriend's
past that are trying to carry out
whatever uh he remains will and
testament is uh but we know based off of
how many episodes we have left we're we
got to be going to to Chicago to the
World's Fair so I think part of his will
in testment maybe is to like find all
other um like Kang variants who are
still winnable or something like that
you know cuz he knows all the evil ones
that are out there from the war but
maybe there's some who were pacifists
who didn't join the war or didn't know
about the war so he's trying to like
recruit some he definitely described a
spectrum right like he he he described
there are like the there are ones so
evil you can't even imagine but then
there are also a couple little Cutie
Pies that just you know they like to
just doodle in their sketchbooks and be
like this is how I'll conquer I'll
conquer benevolently I'll conquer via
green energy uh uh I'll conquer just
with words with Robert's Rules of Order
yes by just making a good case I'll
conquer by creating soilent a a food
sustainability product that doesn't hurt
our Earth uh that's that's that's what
it tastes great when it's in key lime
pie it oh key
lime those candied limes in the key lime
I got to tell you that was my favorite
part of it is they got some lime slices
and they you know put them in a skillet
with some uh boiling sugar yes and Candy
them that takes a lot of effort I I
gotta say I know it it takes all
nutritional value out of it but I will
eat any candied fruit you know I like
regular fruit too I'm not one of those
uh big guys that doesn't like fruits and
vegetables I love them I just love them
in bulk but uh when you candy an orange
or you candy a lemon or you candy a lime
then it's Tommy
time uh and I just candied lemon is one
of the best like candied Citrus I think
one of like the greatest of go me in La
for some candied lemons next week will
[Laughter]
you I'm telling you like I keep bringing
up my love Great British baking show uh
we're talking about Loki but we need to
do a whole series that just reacts to
episodes of The Baker I got to say Eric
of all my friends in the world you'd be
in my top three to go to a candy shop
with I feel like you have that sense of
wonder that that going into like a
person making homemade candies I follow
a candy account on Tik Tok of a guy it's
like an old guy and his daughter and
they just all they do is just make taffy
and candy canes and candy ribbons all
day it just seems so fun and I think
it's in California so let's rent a car
tell your wife you're taking a few days
off tell Kelly it's over I'm tell her
no no she'll figure it out I'll be
back just tell her you're going to see
The Candy Factory with
Tom I've lik Nelson in that episode of
the simpons where I just go I'm going
out for a while
see all right we should focus on Loki
but I just we should I went on a candy
tangent yeah yeah um I imagine that that
World's Fair Chicago is going to have
some delicious sweet yeah and hopefully
long form
improv just the
origin you sir just are you eating a hot
dog yes and it's delicious just charna
howburn as like an 8-year-old girl in
Chicago years some day I'll d State
everyone
here Niche improv
humer I think my favorite thing Toby is
how you still comment on Chara's posts
on Facebook whatever she talks about
stuff like you're right there yes just
let her know I but I always but I
comment encouragingly and people think
that I'm
serious sounds great
Chara excited for you
girl
um wow a lot of inside jokes here but U
yeah in terms of Rona and Miss minute's
plan I think they're trying to recruit a
new Army of successors for k for he
remains like I think he said to raona
rinsler thank you for being on my team I
think we have like you know now there
used to be a whole bunch of different
fronts in the Kang War now I think
there's going to be a Kang Civil War and
I think we're going to see just everyone
in the arena versus like any other
person who can can siphon off to his
side and I think he's having Mis minutes
and ren Slayer start on that path
interesting all right now at the end of
the episode we see Casey gets a hit on a
location but we don't know where other
than it being labeled Q2 on the temp pad
the trailers mostly have her dressed in
a World's fair era costume from what
we've seen so maybe she's looking for
that Kang variant like you said to get a
little Revenge huh I like that maybe
maybe R is going to go in there and do a
little stabby stabby she says he who
remains more like you will all be
remains I I love that idea I love that
idea I mean I think ultimately what's
going to happen in this season Tommy is
that like Miss minutes it's going to be
the villain of this season I think she's
perfectly set up as a villain uh Tera
strong is playing her part in that on
Twitter uh and I think uh we're going to
see a battle a like just a hand toand
fight between kiwan as Obi the OG the
original he remains fighting a hologram
Miss minutes like that perfect zamus who
frame Roger Rabbit battle between those
two I think that's what I want to see in
the finale episod count me in on that
baby Count Me In oh that would be a riot
and Eric speaking of riots we got to get
on over to the nerd riot. shop because I
love wearing this grou shirt I got to be
honest it's one of my favorite shirts
we've ever made but you're wearing
something real special you're wearing
something from our brand new latest and
greatest new rockstars gear featuring
merch inspired by that trickster Loki
and his new gang of friends that we've
now been able to capitalize on right
look at that that's a m shirt we've got
Miss minute shirts we got them baseball
style I don't know who these new
designers are but G dang they got skills
G dang they got skills and the shirts
are comfy now this this Gru shirt will
always be a nearest and dearest to me
hell I'm wearing it to solving as soon
as this show is over to go get to a
wedding I'm not going to go to the
wedding in this shirt but I'm going to
get to the hotel and check in with this
shirt so the city of salang knows that
I'm serious and those of you that know
have fun in salving you can get some
Sweet Treats in salang get those uh what
are those called the lingen berry
pancakes I can't remember I'm going to
look for candied fruits for us in
solving and I'm going to there's going
to be a little surprise for you next
time you're in the new Rockstar's office
back to the merch right now check out
our new line of Loki merch it's so good
this is the best way to support the
channel you guys you buy some shirts
well maybe it's not the best way maybe
if you individually send us all checks
that would be but this really does
support the channel we've got great
merch options they're super fun they're
really cool they're not like
aggressively pandering to just the
direct Studio designs there's no Mouse
ears on these baby there's grou ears and
there's Mobius on a jety Mobius sell
pies Miss Min just such a babe standing
there in all of her beautiful orange
glory good God I I got off track cuz I
was thinking about Miss minutes again I
just want to see how she ticks don't
forget to subscribe to our channels as
well guys all three on the new rock star
Network the Hydra if you will the new
rock stars the Deep dive and of course
the break room near and dear to my heart
we got a big week coming up on new rock
stars uh and the break room and the Deep
dive we have a video coming out on
Monday on the main channel that is about
what is the difference between to be
pruned or to die like pruning versus
death um over on the Deep dive I believe
as of today you can watch uh my deep
dive into Jordan peele's get out my
favorite movie I say I like that God I
can't believe that was so long ago we're
getting old it was so long ago we also
have an analysis on John Carpenter's The
Thing on the Deep dive that's in the
line so for that the thing is my go-to I
I have never watched the thing before
it's going to be one of my Halloween
every year around Halloween I'm not a
big horror movie guy I try to watch a
couple Classics so things on my list
it's so good such a it's a perfect film
um we have we're gonna have a reaction
to episode three uh and uh it's going to
be me with mod and Tommy on inside
Marvel this week so that will be fun and
then our breakdown let's ghost our um
breakdown of episode three uh the Easter
egg will be on the main Channel Thursday
night and then we're going to be uh
continuing to break down gen V uh from
Amazon Prime video uh that's been a
really really good show so far oh one
shot energy huh I think I'll try
it
[Applause]
who so what does one shot's Focus shoe
do
[Music]
eternity
W so uh one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with oneshot
energy today by going to oneshot
energy.com neww rockstars for 10% off
your order now Eric you and mod went in
on this episode a little bit on inside
Marvel and one of the complaints has
been about the lack of emotional payoff
in this episode sylv's Branch didn't
even get pruned do you think these
bombings will come back into play I mean
that's a pretty dramatic thing to have
in a show so do you think they'll come
back this season and maybe we'll
actually feel the consequences of what
docs did which is essentially you know
just wipe out the entire civilizations
and do you think there'll be future
implications to that yeah uh I think I
was way too hard on this episode uh
after watching it the first time I think
I was just so confused by the way it
begins and just how fast the final
battle happens that I don't know I think
when I rewatched it I liked it a lot
more so a lot of people are like going
after me like why are you hating on it
but I think Tommy you and I discover
like if we don't criticize it enough
people yell at us if we uh if we say any
anything negative about it we have
people scream at us if you say anything
positive you're a shill haters and
shills you know what call me a Slater an
AC Slater because we're the coolest guys
in
school can we just give I I just wanted
to let everyone know if you follow any
uh like media Outlet or critic or any
any personality on Twitter or YouTube
and all they say about thing is one type
of thing and if even their reaction to
one movie or episode of TV and that's
their reaction the moment they see it
and they stick with it and their views
never evolve you're not watching an
honest human being honest human beings
can react to things have feelings about
it and their opinions change that's
that's a normal way
I I you know I I I have to say I I agree
with you completely I my first viewing
of this episode I was like first of all
I thought I was watching maybe an out of
sequence episode right like I thought I
was like wait is this labeled wrong or
am I watching something and then I was
like okay no these are the characters
this makes sense but then I agree with
you
100% or I
agreed first of all I I too have evolved
into liking this episode much more upon
a second view the first view though I
was like wait all of this doc stuff is
happening so fast like they figured it
out it was like within like a minute
that they figured it out and stopped it
so yeah I guess I just I I agree and I
think like you know one of the things
that we do try to do here especially at
new rockstars and on the break room on
the Deep dive it's like uh you know we
we try to be emotionally honest so in
the moment if something rubs us the
wrong way we're going to say it but we
also try to be like intellectually
decent so upon looking at it a second
time a third time if we see something
differently which is how the human
experience of life art science
everything is then we can go back and
say that and that doesn't mean the first
thing we said was invalid it just means
that something in our experience with it
has changed and rather than just lie and
keep a keep a company line or keep a
keep a talking point we're going to
change it up that doesn't make anyone a
shill it doesn't make anyone dishonest
it just makes them real so you know I I
think I will always just finding that
like like everything when the discourse
lives on social media it's not an honest
human conversation and people are not
actually talking with each other they're
talking over and past each other and as
we find very often in real life Eric new
you know people who uh take in our
content uh many of the people online who
comment on it are very nice and decent
people but a lot of the people who never
have made a single comment on a new
rockstars video when you meet them in
person can speak passionately about the
channel and validate validate our work
so you know I don't want to get too
stuck on this I don't want to be too
stuck in time I want to talk about time
slipping now we didn't see any time
slipping in this episode but we know
because of trailer footage that there's
more to come so here's my question what
is it exactly that's causing Loki to
time slip and why isn't anyone else
experiencing
this okay yeah so two things let's talk
about time slipping first uh and I do
want to talk about like will the
bombings have implications oh yeah sorry
sorry I jumped ahead I no but I do think
yeah I think time slipping was specific
to Loki and I think it's just because he
as a variant of Sylvie and as uh I think
Loki are basically the anomalistic flaw
to The Matrix of the TVA um not everyone
not every variant is like that but
there's a reason why he remains
recruited a Sylvie and by recruited I
mean he like hunted and and kidnapped
her um and why part of the plan was to
link up l1130 Loki with l11 190 Sylvie
because they're they represent an
anomalistic flaw that logic the system
The Matrix of the of the TVA so when he
gets kicked out of the Citadel in the
season six or season episode one uh
season 1 episode 6 the finale episode he
just kind of instinctively Time Slips
because his his like temporal Aura is
linked with these uh these kind of
Doomsday events where the time Loom is
broken so that's what's happening right
now when when Sylvie you know is
destined to stab he remains that that
his his body already starts to go into
that process and until you know uh
measures can be made to where he can can
kind of Link back with uh with Mobius
there that's the only thing that can
subdue it but we know from Trailer
footage that he will be time slipping
again like at some point in this season
he's going to time slip in and out of
the parking lot like this is going to be
something that he goes back to so he's
destined to Circle back to it but I
think it's specific to being a Loki as
opposed to any variant U But to answer
the question of the the sacred timeline
bomb
um I think the consequences will be like
all these timelines have been bombed I
think the uh elith is going to be over
stuffed with food to eat and I think
it's going to overrun the void with too
many trillions or at least billions of
people and it might just overwhelm like
imagine the the temporal Loom being
overwhelmed with timelines I think elith
is going to be overwhelmed with food
sources to consume so I think it's going
to further make things worse just from
the other end
they can't even hide in the void anymore
then if they you know there's like oh
wow wow wow
wow I love it I love it so that's I
think there will be implications I don't
think we're going to see that stuff but
I do think like elath is just going to
break in the way that I really am I I
find that that that character or Monster
or whatever guard dog elith so
interesting I thought The Taming of
elath uh at the end of episode 5 season
1 was so was such a weird powerful
moment the the revelation of the Citadel
behind him or hit or whatever I don't
know what elath is is it a tiger is it a
Cave of Wonders I think it's a Cave of
Wonders uh I think it's a Mufasa a bit
of a Mufasa bit of a lost smoke monster
yeah and regardless I uh I I I I I'm
curious I need more elith I need more
elith in my life so yeah now you you
yeah you had mentioned some Mobius
things uh in a video so I want to hear
more on that yeah um you could check out
a video that came out on on the channel
on Saturday uh Mobius has been kind of
like kg when it comes to his past life
but uh the most recent episode it seems
like he might have some connection to
the McDonald's with this line about
wanting one of their pies and he might
have some kind of History my theory has
been that Jack the McDonald's employee
might be Mobius at a younger age so when
we met Jack do you think that was young
Owen Wilson young Mobius you know I saw
your Tweet about this this morning and I
gasped audibly I was like wow yes that
would make so much sense my question is
though so here's my here's my thought if
it's not I think there's there's
something there also the pies back then
at McDonald's were deep fried and they
were delicious and now they bake them to
make them healthier and they put less
Apple in them so I don't blame Owen
Wilson uh for wanting to go back to the
80s to eat those Delicious Pies but when
Mobius is questioned about his life on
the timeline he seems so hyperresistant
to deal with it right almost like the
way a person who has experienced trauma
or grief that that they that instead of
processing it they block it or they or
they bottle it I'm wondering if Jack is
his son I'm wondering if Jack is is or
is or his brother or somebody important
to him you know like I don't know if
Mobius is supposed to be Owen Wilson's
age like you were saying in your Tweet
but I do think um I do think there's a
chance that it's like could be a family
member and or or you know or like
I just I guess the only thing that bumps
me is he knew that McDonald so was he is
is oh is Mo the character I keep going
oh the character of O Wilson is Mobius
so uh able to suppress things that he
didn't even have a real reaction there
the only way he could kind of process
being there was just to eat a delicious
a succulent McDonald's meal a meal
that's a good question it's a good
question I think it's possible that
Mobius does not remember his past he
also yeah he he been wiped so many times
that he just yeah but that's so
interesting I think so he he sees his
own self and he's like well he doesn't
have my nose and then forgets that like
he busts his no at some point he had he
had who remains at one point uh and
that's why Ren Slayer to him because
it's like he stood up for her to he who
remains or something I don't know we
should it would be great if they did a
uh explanation for OD Wilson's nose via
plot point in Loki that would be
amazing I mean that's what I was saying
in the video that it could be like a
river Phoenix Last Crusade thing how
they had him cut himself on the on the
chin to justify why Harrison Ford has
cut um but yeah we'll see I think
ultimately we know for sure that Mobis
does remember the historical period of
the early 90s and I can't remember when
they stopped deep frying the Apple more
early more recent I think it's I think
it's a 2000s thing but I do think Eric I
think your uh Mobius being Jack is more
satisfying than Jack being like mob's
son or kid brother or something like
that I mean what a great like what a
powerful one to one moment that like
Sylvie had a weird has like a weird
affinity for the character of Jack you
know it's like I don't know I like it I
like it I just think like the the
character I thought was a one andone but
when he came back in episode two I was
like oh the way that episode ended
there's something with this kid and the
fact that they didn't prune the timeline
right that timeline right right right
right right right yeah I like it I like
it Eric I like it a lot well let us know
in the comments below but before we go
on let's just do another little heat
check we're in the heat check phase
we're between episode two and episode
three uh so I got to say initially after
episode two when I first watched it
feeling like it was like a step down but
after rewatch it I was like okay you
know what no this has still been a solid
season and knowing that we're headed to
1893 Chicago I'm really excited for
episode three I think despite what like
has been printed in The Hollywood
Reporter the worries people have about
the Marvels I think
honestly Loki is like single-handedly
saving Marvel's brand right now this has
been such a good season yeah uh I don't
think it will impact because I think
that the the the uh the the promos for
Loki uh in a thing that normally bothers
me have masterfully shown us a lot but
without showing us too much we still
have footage left from the trailers that
we have not seen yet from the previews
from the from the from the TV spots and
all of those are intriguing there
there's not a lot of just like what you
would call you know uh filler scenes
from trailers it's like we want to see
him in front of that Rockmart right we
want to see him in front of that jet ski
store we want to see Victor timley we
want to see all of these things we want
to see Miss minutes God damn it if for
nothing else we want to see that big
beautiful orange clock face in those
smooth smooth minute hands just
caressing her her face and I wish those
hands were my hands so no it won't
impact the rest of the season I think uh
I'm I'm super pumped for the next four
episodes uh and I'm super excited so
we'll leave it uh there for this episode
of the sneak peek thank you so much for
watching uh and yeah this this this show
the sneak peek we're going to have uh
you're going to see a lot of fun faces
pop up on this every week so um yeah
Tommy this has been awesome chatting
Eric as you can tell by the 15 minutes
of unable footage that we shot for this
episode we enjoy talking to each
other it's my my absolute pleasure I I
love hanging with you every week buddy
release the Costa cut I want to see the
whole thing put the Costa cut out there
come on Costa you coward uh sh no just
kidding shout out to ashel and John
Costa for all the technical work they
put into these shows every week we love
you guys thanks so much we love you guys
and we love you Tommy follow Tommy on
all social media at Tommy Beck told you
can follow me at eaos subscribe to all
three channels in new Rockstar Network
support us by grabbing something from
nerd rot. shop and we'll see you next
week after episode three comes out
thanks for watching everybody see you
next time
[Applause]
[Music]
bye